T
GO AHEAD
TO SAY IT DOESN'T HAVE A PARTYO
IT AND THEst THE OFFENSE THA
BEUSE MAGA IS SEONEAR THAT
ANT OFF.RETED HA
LE SHONT TACTION.
PERMEN'SY. FS A DIGR STAIN WHAA
LIKE.
>>HAE MEA JOHN? T TWANT
T AND
L EN
D LOCA WARRANTY
NDPERSON,
ANTH
FO'SNO IT IS H HAD, BUT  KNO
SOMETHING THAT DEEPLCONCERNED
THE F JUSTIC
RLN'T A  TAKERSN'TUY WHO'S
GOES WHERE NO ONE AS EVER .NGY
OK ISEE AR
G ALL OVER
FACE WHEN THIS IAID GARLANGO BY
BOOK, BUT IS THE BOOK
WE LIV AION
ENVIRONMENT NOW WHERRE -- YOLLIA
THE POLICIES ALL THE GUIDELINES
CRE WITHIN AR OF MINUTES AERE DM
HOURDAYS.
IY AS W
AS IT IS ANNOISHER WAS TO INVEN
OUORUS FROM THE ORIG R>> THANK
>> SHE COVERD
DIOR
ALSO HERE  ET
ANER.
DEFUNDOU WRON MONDAYT HAPPEN
>> YES.
>>O EL ABOUT T HYPOCRISY D IN RI
CALLED THEELS
ENFORCEMENT, BLUE
NG HER U HER UT TICIAN THAT'S A
WEDEFUND FBI, E PLACO TOI THINTI
>> CONGRAN CRENSHAO LOO SOME FU
HERE.YOU CAN'T TO
HE FBI WITHOUT ANYINFORMATION.
MOSTLY BEEN SAYING
USED HERE. >> I THINKS OBO PORT
ACE RIGHT IS NOT
NECESSARILY COMINGN
MACOT TEATOU
TO THEORK TIMES OR
A CINFR RIG?
>> THAT'E T
N  THEY'RE
SA C I DON'T THINK THEHT
REALLY HAS COVER FEELSHOE MEES
IT OUT TO ?
>> IT'S EXTREME NCE
K ON THE FBI FIE
NAANDDICTE TRUMP
TO THIS
KIETORIC 2SO THESE THINGS CONSE
>> I DO REWE CAN
SAYD OR SEA
BUTHLLE KE
WORDS AMPLIFYING PPLU' LIKE D
SAIDO R SIEGE.STT',  MRE
E PLRM STEVE
ONERT OF LANE T  IWAR, THIS U
KNOWCIZED,EAFBI -- ANDNGEALLME '
IMANCONTEXT,CHE NEED
IORT OF P
EXTRISP'S
BASE,  PLIP
SO WHEN YOU HA T AD I WEAPONIZE
PRO TH
WAS  LIMY
THAT'S REALLWERFUL.
>> WT.T ATTACK TH
THAT'S THE